de joséphine aussi quand vous entendez
déjà ces témoignages
géraldine maillet et si vous vient à
l'esprit par cette enquête parce qu'on
al'impression voilà que le monde
hum voilà sort de nouvelles données et
de nouvelles choses tout toutes les
semaines
alors moi je vous dire ce qui m'est
arrivé moi j'ai donc j'ai écrit beaucoup
de romans et à l'époque contre le fait
qu'ils aient présenté le journal de 20
heures il avait aussi une émission
littéraire patrick poivre d'arvor vol
connues vols de nuit et c'était une
émission très prescriptrices est entre
quatre et non en tant que jeune auteur
moi c'était mon premier roman j'étais
très content d'être invité dans cette
émission
c'était plutôt très valorisant vous avez
vous invité à mais moi je vais
rencontrer plein de fois ouais et donc
c'était ma première vraie grosse
émission de télé pour mon roman donc
j'ai rencontré l'émission s'est bien
passé et à la fin de l'émission
effectivement il s'est approché de moi
d'une manière un petit peu cavalière une
sorte de drague un petit peu lourde et
il m'a dit j'ai beaucoup aimé les mots
votre livre et j'aimerais vraiment qu'on
se revoit ce serait bien qu'on se revoie
et j'ai dit mais bien sûr on se reverra
à l'occasion de mon deuxième roman et je
suis parti voilà donc en fait c'était
peut-être insistant de sa part peut-être
que d'autres jeunes filles auraient
pensé que c'était peut-être une drague
ou une manière de je ne sais pas comment
dire sur d'emprise qui vous l'exercez
sur moi moi j'ai senti que c'était une
sorte de 2,2 de drague un peu lourde
mais en tout cas je les jetais
complètement balayées n'a pas été rose
n'est pas il n'a pas été retenu j'ai pas
vécu ça comme une sorte de traumatisme
je me souviens je suis revenu à la
maison j'en ai parlé à mon éditeur j'en
ai parlé à ma maman voilà point barre
voilà et après il m'a reçu à chaque fois
pour tous mes livres il n'a plus du tout
été insistant il n'a plus du tout été
lourd on s'est revus voilà il ya il n'y
a pas eu de problème donc effectivement
quand je dis ça je me dis que peut-être
certaines jeunes filles on n'a peut-être
pas eu la même réaction il ya eu un
rapport de force un rapport de pouvoir
un rapport d'emprise comme moi en tout
cas je n'ai pas je n'ai pas subi